THE MOMENT, KYIV IS MUCH SAFER
THAN IT WAS A WEEK AGO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SAM KILEY IN UKRAINE.
PLEASE STAY SAFE.
>>> TOP OFFICIALS IN THE U.S.
SAY THEY'RE WORRIED THAT CHINA
COULD SEND AID TO RUSSIA TO HELP
IN THE WAR AGAINST UKRAINIAN.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY PROMISED TO PUNISH CHINA
IF IT DOES.
A WARNING PRESIDENT BIDEN
REPEATED DURING A CALL WITH
PRESIDENT XI JINPING THIS
MORNING.
KAITLAN COLLINS REPORTS NOW FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE ON WHAT THE TWO
LEADERS DISCUSSED IN THEIR
NEARLY TWO-HOUR DISCUSSION.
>> Reporter: FOR AN HOUR AND 50
MINUTES TODAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPOKE TO CHINESE PRESIDENT XI
JINPING AS HE SEEKS TO DETER HIM
FROM BAILING OUT RUSSIA.
>> CHINA NEEDS TO SOUND ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY.
IT NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT IT DOES
NOT BACKFILL OR IN ANY WAY
IMPEDE THE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
>> HE ALSO DESCRIBED THE
CONSEQUENCES OF CHINA FOR
PROVIDING MATERIAL SUPPORT TO
RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: BIDEN HOPING THE
PERSUADE THE CHINESE LEADER TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM PRESIDENT
PUTIN AND FIND OUT WHETHER CHINA
PLANS TO ANSWER THE REQUEST FOR
DESPERATELY NEEDED MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
>> WHAT IS CRITICAL IS FOR EVERY
NATION OF THE WORLD TO CALL ON
PRESIDENT PUTIN TO END THIS WAR
OF CHOICE, THIS WAR OF CARNAGE.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
>> Reporter: CHINA HAS REFUSED
TO CALL THE INVASION AN INVASION
OR CONDEMN PUTIN FOR BRUTALIZING
A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
TODAY BIDEN WARNED XI OF THE
CONSEQUENCES IF CHINA PROVIDES
MATERIAL SUPPORT TO RUSSIA AS IT
CONDUCTS BRUTAL ATTACKS AGAINST
UKRAINIAN CITIES AND CIVILIANS.
CHINESE STATE MEDIA SAYS
PRESIDENT XI TOLD PRESIDENT
BIDEN THAT CONFLICT ISN'T IN
ANYONE'S INTEREST AND QUOTE, THE
UKRAINE CRISIS IS SOMETHING WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE.
THE CRITICAL CONVERSATION COMING
AS TOP U.S. OFFICIALS ARE
WARNING THAT RUSSIA IS SPREADING
MORE LIES, INCLUDING ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN AMPLIFIED BY CHINESE
STATE MEDIA.
>> THIS MEETING AND THESE LIES
ARE DESIGNED FOR ONE PURPOSE AND
ONE PURPOSE ALONE.
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR RUSSIA'S
WAR OF CHOICE AND THE
HUMANITARIAN CATASTROPHE IT HAS
CAUSED.
>> Reporter: AS THE U.S. MAN'S
TO SEND $800 MILLION MORE IN
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE,
RUSSIA'S FOREIGN MINISTER IS
CLAIMING THEY'LL VIEW ANY
SHIPMENT OF WEAPONS AS A, QUOTE,
LEGITIMATE TARGET.
RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER LAVROV
SAYS RUSSIA WILL VIEW ANY
SHIPMENTS INTO UKRAINE AS
LEGITIMATE TARGETS.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE
TO THAT COMMENT?
>> THAT'S A THREAT HE HAS MADE
BEFORE.
WE WILL WATCH CLOSELY IF THEY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT THREAT.
>> Reporter: AS THE U.S. TRIES
TO INCREASE THE PRESSURE ON
PUTIN, TOP OFFICIALS ARE MAKING
CLEAR, THEIR GOAL IS NOT TO OUST
HIM FROM OFFICE.
>> DOES THE UNITED STATES
SUPPORT REGIME CHANGE IN RUSSIA?
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT.
THIS IS A DECISION FOR THE
PEOPLE OF RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: NOW, JAKE, DESPITE
THE FACT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SPOKE TO PRESIDENT XI FOR NEARLY
TWO HOURS THIS MORNING, THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS THEY ARE
CONCERNED THAT CHINA MIGHT
ANSWER THAT REQUEST FROM RUSSIA
FOR MORE MILITARY EQUIPMENT AND
SAY THEY'LL BE WATCHING CLOSELY
TO SEE WHAT CHINA DOES GOING
FORWARD.
>> WE HAVE THAT CONCERN.
THE PRESIDENT DETAILED WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS AND CONSEQUENCES
WOULD BE IF CHINA PROVIDES
MATERIAL SUPPORT TO RUSSIA AS IT
CONDUCTS BRUTAL ATTACKS AGAINST
UKRAINIAN CITIES AND CIVILIANS.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING WE'LL BE
WATCHING AND THE WORLD WILL BE
WATCHING.
>> SO THAT CONCERN, HOW IT GOT
AWAY ON THE CALL.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'LL BE
WATCHING.
>> Reporter: ONE OTHER THING TO
KNOW.
WE ASKED THE WHITE HOUSE IF
PRESIDENT XI REFERRED TO THIS AS
AN INVASION DURING THE CALL WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
SO FAR HE HAS NOT CALLED IT ONE
PUBLICLY.
THEY DECLINED TO SAY, JAKE.
>> OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS, SENATOR
BEN CARDIN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU JUST HEARD WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI SAY EVEN
BETWEEN THE NEARLY TWO-HOUR CALL
BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
PRESIDENT XI JINPING, THAT CHINA
WILL HELP RUSSIA IN ITS WAR ON
UKRAINE, DO YOU THINK CHINA WILL
ACTUALLY DO THAT?
>> WELL, JAKE, FIRST GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
UNDERSCORED THE POINT THAT CHINA
NEEDS TO BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY.
ANY COUNTRY THAT ASSISTS MR.
PUTIN IN WHAT HE'S DOING HAS
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PRODUCE
ATROCITIES.
AND I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE
THAT VERY CHEER.
I WOULD HOPE THAT CHINA WANTS TO
BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE HERE.
THE UNPROVOKED ATTACK BY MR.
PUTIN, ANY SUPPORT OF THAT, WILL
CAUSE CONSEQUENCES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> CHINESE, IT IS AN OPPRESSIVE
AUTOCRACY.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY ACCORDING TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT COMMITTING
GENOCIDE OF THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY.
WHAT MAKES ANYONE THINK THEY
WILL CARE WHAT SIDE OF HISTORY
THEY'RE ON?
>> CHINA DOES NOT SHARE OUR
VALUES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND THAT'S
DISAPPOINTING.
WE WOULD HOPE THEIR LEADERSHIP
WOULD UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF RESPECTING THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
STATE.
AND THAT WHEN MR. PUTIN, WHAT
MR. PUTIN IS DOING VIOLATES
EVERY NATIONAL NORM IN REGARD TO
SOVEREIGNTY.
AND CHINA, I THINK, BELIEVES WE
NEED TO RESPECT THE SOVEREIGNTY
OF ITS OWN COUNTRY AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THE LEADERSHIP
WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT MR. PUTIN
CROSSED A LINE.
THAT NO ONE WANTS TO BE ON WHAT
HE'S DOING AND FACILITATING WHAT
HE'S DOING.
>> EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS WHY
THEY WOULD THINK THAT CHINA,
CONSIDERING WHAT IT HAS DONE IN
TIBET AND HONG KONG AND TAIWAN,
WHY CHINA WOULD HAVE ANY SORT OF
BELIEF IN SOVEREIGNTY FOR
ANOTHER COUNTRY, CONSIDERING HOW
THEY BEHAVE WHEN IT COMES TO
TERRITORIES, COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T WANT TO BE CHINESE BUT ARE
BEING FORCED TO BE.
>> WELL, YOU RAISE A VERY VALID
POINT.
RECOGNIZE THAT CHINA'S
TERRITORIAL DISPUTES RELATE TO
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
LEGITIMATELY THEIR COUNTRY
THROUGH EITHER THE RIGHTS OF SEA
OR THROUGH THE HISTORIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TAIWAN AND
MAINLAND CHINA.
THE ISSUE CONCERNING THEIR
DOMESTIC POPULATION AREAS THAT
WE BELIEVE VIOLATE INTERNATIONAL
NORMS, BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT
SOVEREIGNTY ISSUES.
SO I THINK THE SOVEREIGNTY OF A
COUNTRY, EVEN FOR CHINA, WHAT
RUSSIA HAS DONE HAS GONE TOO
FAR.
WE HOPE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT MR. PUTIN DID IS UNPROVOKED
ATTACK AGAINST A SOVEREIGN
NATION THAT WAS PEACEFUL.
I WOULD NOT THINK THAT ANY
LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT WOULD WANT
TO SUPPORT THAT ACTION.
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKY ADDRESSED
WESTERN LEADERS IN A SPEECH
TODAY SAYING, WE SHALL CALL EVEN
LOUD ORDER CERTAIN WESTERN
LEADERS, AND REMIND THEM THAT
THIS WILL BE THEIR MORAL DEFEAT
IF UKRAINE DOES NOT RECEIVE THE
ADVANCE WEAPON THAT'S WILL SAVE
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF OUR
PEOPLE.
NOTE HE'S NOT SAYING THAT ABOUT
THE U.S. MAINTAINING A NO-FLY
ZONE.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT, HE SEEMS TO
HAVE LOWERED HIS REQUEST TO
WITHIN WHERE LEADERS MIGHT
CONSIDER IT TO BE MORE PRACTICAL
AND PRAGMATIC.
IS THE U.S., IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
DOING ENOUGH TO HELP RIGHT NOW?
SHOULD BIDEN BE FACILITATING
POLAND'S PUSH TO GET UKRAINE
THESE MIG JET FIGHTERS?
>> FIRST, LET ME TELL YOU
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S MESSAGE TO
THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE WORLD,
WHAT A POWERFUL MESSAGE.
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE LEADER.
I THINK WE ALL HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR HIS COURAGE AND HIS
LEADERSHIP.
YES, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
DELIVERED.
HE'S DELIVERED DEFENSIVE WEAPONS
THAT HAVE ALLOWED UKRAINE TO
DEFEND ITSELF.
HE'S DELIVERED THE TOUGHEST
SANCTIONS THAT ARE REALLY
CRIPPLING MR. PUTIN AND THE
RUSSIAN ECONOMY.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE'S
DELIVERED INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT,
UNITY, GLOBALLY UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND NOW WE'RE PROVIDING
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE IN
UKRAINE AND IN REGARD TO THE
REFUGEES.
WHAT MR. ZELENSKYY WANTS IS MORE
AND WE ALL WANT MORE.
HE WANTS US TO HAVE A STAYING
POWER.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
PASSED AN IMPORTANT BILL
YESTERDAY THAT DEALT WITH TRADE
ISSUES AND THE ENABLERS TO THOSE
WHO COMMIT THE ATROCITIES.
WE WANT TO SEE THAT DONE.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO DO MORE.
YOU HAVE TO ST